hola de nuevo bueno parece que fue muy
abrumador todo lo de chuck norris gay
sino el vídeo pasado así que haré algo
diferente intentemos simplificar algunas
otras expresiones y bueno veremos que
estamos aplicando ideas que ya conocemos
ideas que con las que ya estamos muy
familiarizados digamos que yo quiero
simplificar la expresión 2 por 3 x 5
esto esto literalmente esto es lo mismo
que 3 x 5 más otro 3 x 5 es lo que
quiere decir 2 x 3 x 5 y esto a que es
igual esto es lo mismo lo podemos
escribir como como dos veces 3x entonces
2 x 3 x más dos veces el 5 así que aquí
es aquí es este dos veces dos veces el 5
entonces más 2 por 5 y tal vez estés
preguntando bueno esta será la propiedad
distributiva estamos distribuyendo el 2
sobre el 3 x + x y en efecto yo te diría
que sí
si es la razón por la que estoy haciendo
esto es principalmente porque quiero
quiero que veas que esto es la propiedad
distributiva y ya lo sabes pero bueno en
fin vamos a simplificar esto cuando
multiplicamos el 2 por el 3x entonces
obtienes 6x ajá aquí es esto es igual a
6 x y multiplicas el 2 por el 5 y
obtienes 10 entonces más 10 y ahora
intentemos intentemos algo más ahora una
vez más estas son cosas que tú ya sabes
digamos digamos que yo tengo tengo 7 por
3 y 3 y menos 5 y esto menos menos 2 por
digamos que te gustan 4 y entonces más 4
james veamos si podemos simplificar esto
trabajemos con esto trabajemos con
primero este lado de la expresión aquí
tenemos 7 por 3 ya menos 5 simplemente
simplemente tenemos que distribuir el 7
sobre esto así es 21 y menos menos ten
cuidado con el signo aquí aquí tenemos
estamos multiplicando no por 5 sino por
menos 5 y eso es menos 35 menos 35 y ya
quedó este lado ahora vamos con el lado
derecho tal vez tú quieres hacer el 2
por 10 y 2 por 4 james luego restar los
si lo haces distribuyendo el signo menos
si va a funcionar pero a mi gusto me
gusta pensar en esto como el menos 2 los
voy a distribuir tenemos menos 2 por 10
luego menos 2 por 4 y así es que lo que
vamos a hacer aquí es
es menos 2 por 10 tenemos esto es igual
a menos 20 menos 20 luego menos 2 por 4
james será igual a menos 8 y
entonces aquí esto es igual a menos 8 y
james y ya terminamos eso fue todo no a
uno porque podemos podemos sumar
términos semejantes no podemos sumar el
veintiuno yale menos 35 porque no son
semejantes así que bueno tenemos aquí 21
james y tenemos el -8 veamos aquí sería
entonces aquí tenemos 21 y le restamos
menos 8 le restamos este menos 8 y nos
quedan a 21.8 eso es 13 nos queda
entonces 13 y es 21 21 y 28 y 36 luego
luego tengo yo el menos 35 y el menos 20
aquí este
aquí es menos 35 y menos 20 eso se
simplifica menos 55 y todo esto usando
la propiedad distributiva y acomodando
términos semejantes llegamos a 13 y
menos 55 es la respuesta final